[Musique]
jean castex à lui reçu à matignon les
responsables de l'opposition pour parler
de l'épidémie trois heures et voici ce
qui nous donne en sortant c'est une
réunion qui s'inscrit dans l'objectif la
marque de fabrique qui est la nôtre qui
est celle de la transparence absolue
alexandre benalla vous avez l'ancien
collaborateur des modèles macro
évidemment a été hospitalisée à paris en
urgence relative il aurait été
diagnostiqué positif au corona virus le
premier ministre nous a rappelé qu'il
fallait s'habituer à vivre avec le virus
or s'habituer à vivre avec le virus ça
veut dire s'habitue à vivre avec le port
du masque qui maintenant qu'il est
disponible en quantité est devenu
obligatoire mais n'est toujours pas
gratuit chu de nice certains personnels
soignants contaminé je n'ai pas qu'à
contacter contaminé compte et est obligé
de continuer à travailler
oui c'était mal à confirmer vous avez
interpellé le ministère de la santé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous avez
retour je n'ai aucun retour vous avez
affirmé que les dix-huit militaires qui
composaient l'équipage de l'estérel
avait été testé vous avez affirmé qu'ils
avaient été confinés
maintenez-vous que ces personnels ont
été testés la vérité c'est que le
triptyque tester tracé isolé ne
fonctionne pas il fonctionne pas parce
qu'il ya trop de lenteur entre le moment
du dépistage et le moment des résultats
et que ensuite l'application stop covin
ne fonctionne pas ayant juré de dire la
vérité je me dois de vous dire que j'ai
dit quelque chose d' inexact le 4 mars à
france 2 ce que j'ai dit en effet c'est
que les équipages qui était de retour de
van à bord de l'estérel avait été testée
c'est est un raccourci
nous avons apporté je crois les réponses
on a eu peu de réponses nous n'avons pas
toutes les réponses mais ça s'est un peu
qu'est ce que vous voulez un petit peu
l'exercice qui veut ça autant de
questions que nous avons posées sur la
table
sur lesquels nous attendons des réponses
à cette heure nouvelle cartographie de
l'épidémie de coville a été communiquée
le nombre de départements en zone rouge
passe de 55 à 69 pour ces zones
plusieurs seuil d alerte sont créés ce
qui implique une série de nouvelles
restrictions
l'attention se focalise en particulier
sur les grandes villes 8 dont paris sont
en zone d' alerte renforcée dans ces
villes à partir de lundi des bars et
restaurants devront fermer au plus tard
à 22 heures nous avions
par ailleurs un pays où la culture du
mas n'existait pas c'est ce que j'ai
essayé d'exprimer gelé mal exprimé je
sais que c'est vous dire oui il ya un
malaise qui est profond en effet on est
un jeune parti en partie qui a
finalement que quatre ans d'existence en
partie qui emporte avec lui je crois
beaucoup d'attentes
le congé paternité va doubler et passer
de 14 à 28 jours 7 jours supplémentaires
seront accordées aux paires de jumeaux
ou de triplés un mois au sein desquels
il y aura saisi obligatoire pour chaque
jeune femme lorsque l'enfant arrive au
monde
il n'y a aucune raison que ce soit juste
la main s'en occupe les citoyens sont
résignés c'est aussi à cause de vous
mais ses deux meilleurs marqueurs
politiques mais j'en prends ma part
robert j'en prends ma part je ne dis pas
que depuis trois ans nous avons tous
réussi si nous avions tout réussi de
fait nous aurons une n'aurions pas eu
ces résultats au moment des élections
municipales au des législatives
partielles visite de marlène schiappa
strasbourg la ministre déléguée auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur en charge de
la citoyenneté est venu parler
harcèlement de rue on ne peut pas
accepter aujourd'hui en france une femme
se sentent en danger soir se les soient
menacés ou frappés en raison de sa tenue
mais en raison pour toute raison que ce
soit et qu'elle ne puisse pas se sentir
en sécurité et librement dans la rue je
vous avoue que c'est quelque chose qui
m'anime un peu et qui m'énerve beaucoup
parce que voilà j'ai des petites soeurs
qui peuvent aussi se retrouver dans ces
situations je vous disais tout à l'heure
qui a eu plus de 1800 verbalisation
c'est beaucoup mais je crois qu'on peut
aller plus loin avec gérald darmanin
nous avons demandé aux préfets de
doubler ces verbalisations
et pour cela nous souhaitons lever tous
les freins qui peuvent exister sur le
terrain pour accompagner au mieux les
forces de l'ordre dans cette démarche de
verbalisation du harcèlement de rue pour
enfin éradiquer ce fléau